in 2006 while living in Nome Halford
kikuna blacked out and assaulted his
girlfriend choking her with a belt he
fled the scene before police could
arrest him
the crimes involved are assault for
domestic violence for two years Alfred
has eluded local authorities now trooper
Sears is making the trip to bring him to
justice she's being flown by her husband
like many Alaska state troopers assigned
to rural post investigator Sears is also
a licensed pilot with no road system and
frozen water waves era travel to the
villages is more than a mere convenience
it's the only means of transportation
that's part of the danger that a lot of
folks don't realize is just responding
to what we do on a daily basis Alaska
leads the nation and aircraft accidents
we fly everywhere
the flight to the nearby native village
is brief less than 30 minutes serve you
waiting for the troopers is the village
Public Safety Officer or vpso officer
Alana escorts them into town
from late fall to late spring the
villages gravel roads are covered in
over 4 feet of snow roads around town
get so drifted there's so much snow drip
that the only way to get around is on
four-wheelers snow machine
officer atlanta briefs trooper Sears on
the situation the person that we're
looking for in Alfred is that his
mother's house but it kind of sounds
like maybe alfred has gotten an idea
that he might get arrested on this
warrant
with no backup and only a standard-issue
Glock pistol they head to the house
there's no back door is there on this
place okay Alfred
trooper Sears immediately smells
marijuana hands out of your pocket
Alfred Alfred cooperates but his
mother's not so helpful I need you to
stop okay um you and I are gonna go to
know him on that warrant all right
you're gonna have to deal with it with
the court
they take Alfred into custody but his
mother grows more irritated
she wants me pissed off at me versa
you
I I don't know what to tell you about
that at the Public Safety Office
she places Alfred in a holding cell I've
been hiding out here for the last three
years trying to stay away from from the
alcohol in trouble you have the right to
remain silent anything you say can and
will be used in Oklahoma makes very good
kind of violent when I've got alcohol so
here I am No
just hours later it's time to transport
Alfred back to Nome although Alfred
seems compliant trooper Sears never
takes any chances when flying with a
prisoner everybody's always handcuffed
in a plane I always sit in the back of
the plane so that they're the furthest
away from the pilot that I can possibly
get them I mean they could you know try
to hurt him and make the plane go down
so I always transport somebody with the
thought that they don't care what
happens but they're not going to go to
jail
I'm living up here find it here rather
than the city
I'll be missing out with them so I'll
have a place has come home to laying it
out